l'espoir des amateurs de baseball de
retrouver une équipe à montréal ne
repose plus sur grand chose c'est le
chapitre est clos mais stephen bronfman
a confirmé que la ligue de baseball
majeur fermé la porte au projet de ville
soeur une garde partagée de l'équipe des
rays de tampa bay une demi saison en
floride et la fin à montréal dans un
stade encore hypothétique 2009 comprend
le plus dur dit le propriétaire de
l'équipe c'était d'en informer ceux qui
ont travaillé très fort sur ce projet et
ces dernières sont pour nous à digérer
parce que j'en dis oui tellement de fois
est la fin étant dit non
la ligue de baseball majeur n'a pas
communiqué les raisons du refus mais le
groupe baseball montréal y voient de la
frilosité peut-être à fin de journée le
comité exécutif en dit c'est quoi oui
c'est pas mauvaise idée mais on veut pas
être les premières de faim
valérie plante s'est dit déçu comme
beaucoup de montréal et écrit-elle tout
en assurant que montréal est une ville
de baseball que ce n'est que partie
remise quant au site du bassin peel il
ne faudrait pas s'empresser de le
développer selon la chambre de commerce
si un jour on a l'opportunité d'avoir du
baseball majeur à montréal dans
plusieurs années passent
mais la construction même du stade a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre depuis
plusieurs mois l'époque question que
notre gouvernement met un sou des
contribuables la da est ce que les
réticences politiques à injecter des
fonds ont pu peser dans la balance est
ce que ce sont plutôt les joueurs qui
n'appuyait pas le projet ce cas des
joueurs vont vouloir se déplacer d'une
ville à une autre durant 16 ans il ya
des normes à défi et il reste maintenant
celui de concilier le rêve de revoir une
équipe ici et le besoin d'aménager ce
secteur au très grand potentiel au coeur
de la ville ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal